let's go now to Ron DeSantis when we say
the Republican primary of 2024
Ron DeSantis isn't actually in that
primary at this point in time he may
announce he may not one of the problems
Ron DeSantis is having is his
personality and Trump posted to truth
social the other day
that uh that DeSantis needs a
personality transplant and he does and
here is an example clearly DeSantis has
been advised by someone I guess you've
got to be more bubbly or whatever
he sounds ridiculous and it so obviously
contrived he's like pretending to be
bubbly now this is DeSantis over the
weekend at the feinstra family picnic in
Iowa this new DeSantis is not
particularly credible but many maybe
some people will like the new bubbly
DeSantis
people will will say to me they be like
Governor why aren't other Republicans
doing what you're doing in Florida and I
say they are doing it and they say where
I say they're doing it in Iowa and in
fact this whiny Voice by the way is
really tough I was here in March and
someone kind of took note and they're
like man look all the stuffs I was doing
Iowa was like the Florida of the Midwest
they said but are you guys following
this I want to let you know after
watching all the good stuff you've done
in Iowa it may be that Florida is the
Iowa the southeast so we'll see there
you go wow a new bubbly DeSantis with a
new personality maybe that's going to
appeal to people he then went to I guess
a diner or a restaurant of some kind
with Mike Pence and if you want if you
want a a list of people not to take
personality modeling from
I would put my Mike Pence at the top of
that list and here they sit down for
some kind of meal who knows if it's real
or fake or whatever take a look at this
foreign
and as you can see Ron DeSantis sitting
very very strongly
all right unclear whether anybody
ordered any food or what the deal with
that was and then we'll just go now to
the closing of Ron desantis's little
speech there at the feinstra family
picnic and he tries to energize the
crowd with one of these crescendos but
it only sort of works the crowd seems to
understand this is like a crescendo
finish so they do play along and clap
but it all feels very very forced
it occurred to me that you can have the
best Declaration of Independence in the
world you could have the best
constitution in the world but if you
don't have people that are willing
throughout throughout our history to
stand up put on that uniform risk their
lives and in many instances give that
last full measure of devotion then it
isn't going to amount to very much and
so we are not called upon to make
sacrifices of that magnitude but we're
also called upon to do battle in the
political Arena so what I say to you as
Republicans put on the full armor of God
take your stand stand firm for truth we
must fight the good fight we must finish
the race and we must keep the faith I
can tell you this I am proud of what
we've done in Florida inspiring an
electric speech as you can see I'm
thankful we're Governor Reynolds and the
team have done in Iowa but I've only
begun to fight thank you all God bless
you it's so great to be in Iowa
thank you so much
thank you God bless you all
it all feels so empty
it feels vapid it feels
ridiculous
and yet it's like a pantomime of a real
campaign with a real candidate now he
may declare and it may become a real
campaign and I guess to some degree that
will make him a real candidate the
numbers look very bad for DeSantis I
want someone to run against Trump I want
someone to credibly do it the numbers
just don't seem to be falling into
Santa's favor so we'll see what decision
he ultimately makes and he has to make
that decision soon I think within the
next four to six weeks or that's going
to do it did you know that half of
Americans are deficient in vitamins A
and C as well as magnesium if you keep
your diet nutritionally balanced all the
time you can get everything you need but
half of Americans don't and it can
really impact how you feel our sponsor
athletic greens makes it super easy I
mix one scoop of ag1 from athletic
greens into water it tastes great I get
all of the high quality vitamins and
minerals I need from Whole Food sourced
ingredients I don't have to Fumble
around with bottles capsules individual
vitamins and things like that I just
don't have the time you should see
what's going on at my house ag1
simplifies everything I'm covering my
nutritional bases for the entire day
super easy easy to stick to as well and
dramatically more cost effective than
getting all of these different vitamin
supplements go to athletic greens.com
Pacman for a free year supply of vitamin
D I've talked about vitamin D many times
plus five free ag1 travel packs the link
is down below